the last 24 hours have been some of the
craziest and most disturbing in many
ways in the sort of news cycle that
we've seen in weeks and we're going to
talk about the sean hannity text
messages we're going to talk about the
trump riot anniversary and donald trump
cancelling his press conference
scheduled for tomorrow but before we do
any of that
i have what is one of the
wildest interviews that i have seen
certainly in months it is an interview
that took place on msnbc
host ari melber interviewed peter
navarro peter navarro was donald trump's
assistant he was assistant to the
president for a period of time he was
trump's director of trade and
manufacturing policy he was the national
defense production act policy
coordinator
and he is freely admitting
that he was one of the planners
of the attempted coup to steal an
election that donald trump didn't win i
don't think we need really more
introduction i'm just gonna get right
into the material
peter navarro admits to the entire thing
here and it is
let's just get into the clips because
there's just so much this first clip is
kind of the back story
why did peter navarro start developing
with trump this plan for a coup well it
was all based on false beliefs slash
lies slash
misunderstandings slash distortions
let's start right there
sure the back story is while i was in
the administration after the election
beginning on thanksgiving i produced
what would be an exhaustive three volume
report i went over tens of thousands of
pages of documents and proved
that the election was on all likelihood
stolen through fraud and election
irregularities that's the back
background on january 6th that's the
green bay
that's false but i the question for the
start of the interview
will yes it is fine but that's the
question for the start of the interview
navarro says we'll disagree about
whether the election really was or
wasn't stolen
you have to put aside the disagreement
to proceed and ari melber ultimately
does it but
everything is predicated on that and so
it's sort of the crucial point that that
entire premise was untrue let's continue
i just want to i just want to make sure
here that we're kind of going by rules
of the road the question is yeah i know
and you'll get time to talk you've got
to say that and and what i'm saying is
that i don't have to say anything sir
i'm asking you the question is
what was the plan itself and who was in
on it right exactly and i'm going to
tell you that the the plan was simply
this we had over a hundred congressmen
and senators on capitol hill ready to
implement the sweep the sweep was simply
that we were going to challenge
the the results of the election in the
six battleground states they were
michigan pennsylvania uh
georgia wisconsin uh nevada and and
basically these were the places where we
believe that if the votes were sent back
to those battleground states
and looked at again that there would be
enough concern amongst the legislatures
that
most or all of those states would
decertify the election now of course
that wasn't true it didn't happen there
was no such evidence but this is the
same plan that was written up in the
memo by trump's lawyer so it's all
coherent there it's there's no doubt as
to whether that was the plan it was i
would throw the election to the house of
representatives and i would say to you
here ari that all of this again i was it
was in
in the lanes legally it was prescribed
by the constitution there is a provision
to go rather than through the electoral
college to the house of representatives
and all this required
was peace and calm on capitol hill and
at 1 p.m
ted cruz senator ted cruz and gosart a
representative started the green bay
sweep beautifully so the the premise
here is had it not been for the riots
had it not been for the riots
they would have had a shot at carrying
this plan forward which is a new way
that they are sort of denouncing the
some of them are pretending there were
no riots some of them are arguing that
the riots were peaceful in one sense the
riots were part of the plan as far as
trump was concerned but some of these
people who had what they thought was a
more clever way to steal the election
are saying actually the violence got in
the way because it interrupted what we
were going to do have pence reject
electors etc now we get to just an
incredible part where ari melbourne
straight up says to navarro
you're describing a coup do you realize
that take a look at this incredible
video rather than through the electoral
college to the house of representatives
and all this required
was peace and calm on capitol hill and
at 1 pm
ted cruz senator ted cruz and gosart a
representative started the green bay
sweep beautifully challenging the
results of arizona here's the most
important thing i can tell you about
this
the the thing that we were trying to
deal with was was a media which refused
to acknowledge any kind of possible
fraud or irregularities right let's get
into it i've given you peter i've given
you i've given you some time here and i
think you you've explained that and i'm
going to follow up here and i want us to
have a back and forth but that involves
both of us
you just described a way yeah you just
described
this plan
as a way to take an election where the
outcome was established by independent
secretaries of state by the voters of
those states and legal remedies have
been exhausted with the supreme court
never even taking let alone siding with
any of the claims that you just referred
to so legally they went nowhere and then
you're describing a way that the
incumbent hold on hold on you will get
your turn i just let you go for a while
let's go this back and forth sir
then
you will use the incumbent losing
party's power that was the republican
party that was losing power
to overtake and reverse that outcome
do you realize you are describing a coup
no i totally reject many of your
premises there first of all the election
was still in doubt and would be until it
was certified second the idea now that
that isn't you cannot ever satisfy that
because he is saying the election is in
doubt until it's certified
but his plan was to prevent its
certification based on alleged doubts
that he is raising that can never be
satisfied you can never satisfy that and
ari melbourne is is pointing out the
crucial part
all of these independent thing
individual secretaries have stayed in
different states many republicans said
there isn't evidence for this so you
check that off the list courts
throughout i think it was 63 different
complaints that were made
maybe one was sort of
provisionally accepted on theoretical
grounds but
courts did not find that their claims
were with merit the supreme court
declined to take it up so at a certain
point you can't say
we are acting on the basis of
x that justifies it because every legal
and sensible empirical remedy had been
exhausted and had been rejected and then
he says well until it's certified then
it is in doubt but you're the one
preventing its certification it's a
circle
that secretaries of state particularly
in michigan and
and pennsylvania were like innocent
parties i mean jocelyn benson and kathy
bookfar the secretary of state in
michigan and pennsylvania they were put
in power by george soros
for the express purpose of shifting the
playing field wow
wow
so then lastly here
why wasn't navarro more involved in
pushing mike pence to do the thing they
wanted him to do remember trump wanted
pence to reject this and to stop that
and to seat a different slate of
electors and navarro seems to say he was
basically kept away from mike pence
conversation why wouldn't he listen to
you do you think why wouldn't he listen
to you
well i talked about in the in trump time
book his chief of staff mark short who
is a koch network conservative meaning
that an he's a never trumper basically
walled off vice president pence from the
day mark took took chief of staff's
duties back in 2018 and it was a sad
story mike was always good to me until
that day the thing about mike's betrayal
of president trump which is really
interesting is he never shared the legal
analysis of his general counsel greg
jacob right and mark short with pat
again that really peter that brings us
back
but that brings us back to the same
point
and this may be this may be relevant sir
in future elections which is
don't you think somebody would have
thought of this if the incumbent
administration through the president or
the vice president could just cancel the
election outcome because he goes down to
the senate well then a lot of people
would try to stay in power we have an
entire system designed to thwart and i
want to say this respectfully but it's
the truth people like you to stop people
like you who think that you can anoint
yourself the reviewers of the voters of
the american people of what they
lawfully did that you trump the supreme
court no pun intended people like you
are what the constitution are designed
to stop and it worked and it did stop
you which i guess brings us to
you know incredible i mean truly
incredible he's admitting to the entire
thing and it was all based on their
opinion
which was rejected
or not corroborated by every secretary
of state that was pulled into it by
every court that was pulled into it and
ultimately the supreme court saying
there's not even anything here for us
opting not to take this up despite
having uh three justices on it selected
by donald trump
this is exhibit a evidence admitting to
the entire thing pulling together every
aspect of it every aspect of it it's
incredible
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free when you go to the link right
underneath this video